we have a voicemail number two one nine
two david p here's a voicemail that came
in take a listen to this David I'm like
twenty minutes into this interview with
Jesse Lee Peterson and just watching
fellows clothes from the past watching
especially your interviews with him I'm
convinced there has to be something
wrong with this guy yeah I mean like
when I watch someone like Gavin McGinnis
or Richard Spencer or these disgusting
right-wing I'm you know there's no right
wing is putting it lightly for some of
them racist misogynist whatever when I
hear them I get you know I get disgust
that I get angry I get it just it it
makes me sick when I heard Jesse Lee
Peterson say the things he says what's
some of the stuff he says is even more
crazy than what they say I'm not even I
don't even I feel sorry for the man I
feel like there's something not right
it's going on like I don't know I just
think he's so out there and the things
he says I have no idea how this thing
has a following
I just think it's so they're so
obviously like yes baffled by how people
listen to this man and actually think
okay so yes I appeared when I was in LA
over the weekend I appeared on Jesse Lee
Peterson's show he is he claims to be
against identity politics but he's a
self-described black conservative he
describes himself that way but he's
against identity politics imagine the
irony of that I am going to talk about
the behind the scenes of the interview
and the very unfortunate revelation or I
guess fortunate depending on your point
of view he's not playing a character he
is exactly the same off-camera as he is
on I also don't understand how he has a
following I looked at the comments that
his followers were we're posting on
YouTube during our live stream ninety
percent anti-semitic yeah and we're
gonna I'll go into detail about it on
the bonus show we will talk about my
debate with Jesse Lee Peterson quote
debate will talk about my time at
Politico and a whole bunch of other
stuff today's bonus show is going to be
it's gonna be one for the books Pat mark
this one down this is one of the good
ones
ww join pakman.com and patreon.com slash
david pakman show two ways to get access
to the bonus show and boy is today's
going to be a good one